la fin d'année est cruciale pour
beaucoup d'entreprises
ici près de 750 intérimaires vont être
embauchés pour renforcer l'effectif en
période de fêtes des intérimaires qui
suivent une formation spécifique au sein
de l'entreprise on est avec un
instructeur ben personnel on peut dire
et nous explique pas à pas notre le
travail qu'on doit effectuer donc en
même temps pape a raison je vous ai dit
bin donc une bean en même temps il nous
dit que c'est une case les agences
d'intérim locales sont également
sollicités elles reçoivent beaucoup de
candidats aux profils divers
on n'est pas sur des compétences
spécifiques mais plus sûr sur un
savoir-être on va dire sur un dynamisme
une motivation
ces contrats d'intérim peuvent pour
certains débouchés sur des cdi
j'ai fait
trois contrats de suisse avec une petite
carence à la fin et puis en venant de ma
carence j'ai eu une proposition dans
rouge et là ça fait un mois et demi que
j'attends ont bossé pour le site de
chalon nous allons passer d'à peu près
320 330 personnes en cdi en début de
cette année à 500 personnes ont fait
payer à la fin de l'année et l'apport
d'intérimaires permet la fluidité des
commandes près d'un million de colis
sont expédiés au moment des fêtes par
l'entreprise